ja hallo thomas wir haben ja gerade den
alarm draußen gehört der mindestens zehn
minuten ging und gerade wieder alle
draußen in der stadt in kiew also man
stellt sich darauf ein oder sind großer
sorge dass es neue luftangriffe heftige
neue luftangriffe geben könnte denn das
ist die zeit wird putin zuschlägt immer
dann wenn es nacht wird das war in den
vergangenen nächten genauso und
gleichzeitig sieht es so aus dass die
angeblichen friedensverhandlungen die
russland will jetzt dafür vor allem
benutzt werden um erst mal truppen zu
verlegen und wir haben in verschiedenen
von verschiedenen quellen und
bildern bereit belege dafür dass neue
macht diebe truppen in die ukraine
verlegt wird
paule wie nah sind denn die truppen vor
kiew du hattest heute auch wieder
gelegenheit mit vitali und wladimir
klitschko zu sprechen die sprachen
teilweise von 7 8 km vielleicht 20
kilometer muss man wirklich damit
rechnen jetzt verlieren wir gerade dein
bild weil du einen anruf bekommen was
passiert bei skype gesprächen immer
wieder wie wir wie wir lernen aber jetzt
sehen wir dich ja auch wieder paul
muss man damit rechnen dass sie
tatsächlich in diese stadt kommen und
wie wollen sie sich da zu recht finden
wir haben vorhin mit peter helga
gesprochen wir konnten sehen wie die
stadt ist schwarz es ist dunkel alle
straßenschilder sind abgeschraubt dort
die müssen doch irren durch diese stadt
wenn sie überhaupt rein kommen
thomas eine bodenoffensive würde in der
nacht nicht stattfinden hier geht es
jetzt darum wie viele raketen heute
runter regnen auf die hauptstadt wie
viele luftangriffe es geben könnte wie
viele akteure eingesetzt wird da hat man
so ein bisschen die bilder vor auch noch
die gestern nach wo man die blitze am
himmel gesehen hat und wo man die
einschläge und explosionen gesehen hat
und die schweren systeme die davon
russland eingesetzt worden also die
sorge ist dass genau diese systeme
und andere weitere dann gegen die
hauptstadt eingesetzt werden könnten
weil putin zunehmend frustriert scheint
wie die offensive eben gegen die ukraine
läuft der patriotismus der sich auch
hier in der ukraine entwickelt hat wir
sehen wie viele menschen sich gemeldet
haben zu zivilen verteidigung wir sehen
wie viele menschen bereit sind ihr land
zu verteidigen gesehen wie positiv die
lenz die der präsident immer noch ist
wie er es schafft über soziale kanäle zu
kommunizieren und dabei immer optimismus
zu versprühen also er ist wahrscheinlich
der ungewöhnlichste kriegspräsident
aller zeiten sicherlich auch mit dem
hintergrund zu erklären nämlich dem dass
er bis vor drei jahren mit der politik
gar nichts zu tun hatte ein glücklicher
bahn sind biografie schon jetzt flogen
sie lenski und wir müssen schauen was
dann am ende die strategie ist von
wladimir putin hier was kiew angeht
bislang war man davon ausgegangen dass
sie die stadt nicht komplett zerstören
will dass er darauf setzt dass die
menschen ihre waffen abgeben und dass er
ihr zumindest erst einmal ein reiten
kann um dann eine puppet regierung einen
präsidenten zu installieren zu seinem
gunsten aber das wird alles nicht so
leicht sein und das erlebt er gerade und
da ist die frage wie wird darauf
reagiert wird er tatsächlich bereit sein
zu verhandeln und zugeständnisse zu
machen ich glaube eher nicht putin dach
diesen kriegt aus deiner sicht nicht
verlieren schon ihr dort sozusagen bei
der propaganda etwas zu passieren sie
wussten jetzt zugeben auch in den
nachrichten dass sie verluste erlitten
haben dass es tote verletzte gibt all
das kann eine stimmung in russland
schnell drehen gleichzeitig kann die
ukraine im prinzip bei solchen
verhandlungen ja auch nichts geben sie
kann ja nicht sagen gute dann geben wir
der teile unseres landes im gegenteil
das wäre eine gelegenheit zu sagen raus
mit euch und jetzt wollen wir auch noch
die krim zurück haben aber paul die
frage noch mal das war ja die große
hoffnung dass eben die stadt nicht
zerstört wird gerechnet ihr tatsächlich
mit massiven bombardements oder
raketeneinschlägen heute nacht
ja das ist wovon die geheimdienste wovon
die politische elite wovon meine quellen
in kiew ausgehen dass es diese
luftschläge geben wird wie heftig sie
dann sein werden wird fand denen das
gleiche gab es allerdings auch bis
gestern nach da war man davon
ausgegangen dass es ähnlich wie ein
archiv sein würde das passierte dann
nicht wie waren gestern drei mal in dem
bunker während der nacht und im
vergleich zum vor nach zum vorabend war
die bombardierung geringer also das ist
sehr schwer einzuschätzen
möglicherweise war will man jetzt auch
zumindest scheinbar diese friedens
vermeintlichen friedensgespräche nicht
völlig eskalieren aber wieder die
kriegsstrategie wladimir putins ist
sowas das ist wirklich überhaupt nicht
zu erkennen was ich merke ist dass auch
die bildruhe brüder durchaus nervöser
werten ich habe vor zwei einer stunde
mit ihnen telefoniert
da sieht man dann auch wie vladimir
klitschko sich eine schutzweste
überzieht ein helm trägt also man
bereite dich auf alle möglichen
szenarien vor in dieser stadt nur eins
ist klar diese schnelle totale
niederlage von der russland wo der
wladimir putin ausgegangen ist die hat
es nicht gegeben paul bei uns im studio
an der stelle wo du sonst auch oft
stehst ist stephan thomae der
stellvertretende fdp fraktions vize
vorsitzender um nach erkennt kiew sehr
gut und ich will ihm die gelegenheit
geben die eine frage zu stellen vielen
dank herr ronzheimer freut mich
einerseits sie zu sehen also diesen
umständen besonders schlimm wie sind die
verhältnisse in der stadt ist die
versorgung der bevölkerung
sichergestellt ich hab natürlich auch
bekannte freunde in kiew wie ist denn
die lage dort kommen die menschen als
notwendig gibt es wasser sanitäre
einrichtungen lebensmittel medikamente
ist all das gewährleistet in kiew zur
zeit
nein das ist auf dauer nicht
gewährleistet
ich habe dazu heute auch mit dem
bürgermeister gesprochen und wir haben
bereits vor einer katastrophe dass die
verlegung und natürlich insbesondere die
logistik von lebensmitteln und
medikamenten nicht mehr funktioniert
weil es hier eben diese ausgangssperre
gibt nicht nur nachts sondern auch
tagsüber und das wird wann wird diese
körper diese ausgangssperre auch nicht
ewig machen witali klitschko hat 36
stunden als begründung oder genannt dass
man mit provokationen innerhalb der
stadt umgehen müsste und das bedeutet
jetzt aber dass alle wahnsinnig nervös
sind auf den straßen das haben wir
erlebt obwohl im auto des bürgermeisters
saßen dass da mit einer schusswaffe auf
uns gerichtet gezielt wurde die menschen
wahnsinnig hektisch waren weil sie
wirklich befürchten dass es weitere
provokationen gibt aber sie sprechen
dann ganz ganz wichtigen punkt an der
für viele teile in der ukraine eine
rolle spielt denn wenn die stadt
eingekesselt würde und das steht absolut
zu befürchten in den nächsten tagen
schon gestern ist es sei kurz davor dann
könnte natürlich russland versuchen auch
alle
wege sperren und güter zu sperren die
dann noch in die stadt kommt herr thoma
sie setzen sich ja eine für humanitäre
aktionen
was können sie tun was kann deutschland
jetzt in dieser situation tun es kommen
ja auch immer mehr hunderttausende
flüchtlinge sind im ganzen land
unterwegs und immer mehr kommen auch
über die grenze auf deutsch spielen sich
dramatische szenen an und viele können
ja nur gerade den einen koffer wir haben
immer wieder diese kleinen rollis
gesehen diesen einen koffer mitnehmen
und mehr nicht das stimmt dies ganz
besonders dramatisch die menschen haben
heute ganz gut zwischendurch kaulitz
gegangen ehe bleibt ruhig bei uns wir
bleiben zusammen im gespräch solange du
halt kannst ja zu ihrer frage in der tat
die menschen haben sich darauf
eingestellt dass sie bald ihre heimat
verlassen und haben nicht vorgesorgt
packen jetzt das notwendigste manchmal
greift man die kinder gerne schnell
vorher wo er sich gerade kommen von der
schule vom kindergarten von den
großeltern und macht sich auf den weg
hat noch versucht die stadt zu verlassen
und uns gen westen zu fahren was wir
jetzt als deutschland vielleicht
beitragen könnten ist kurzfristig und
zwar sofort ganz schnell dort wo die
menschen die grenzen überschreiten zu
polen slowakei zum ganze romane das sind
die vier angrenzenden westlichen
nachbarländer der ukraine dort eine task
force zu entsenden um menschen zu
registrieren zu wissen wer kommt wo an
sie wird auch zu verteilen das muss ganz
schnell gehen die die schlangen an den
ukrainischen seite der grenze sind sind
kilometer lang 20 30 km weil es lange
dauern bis die menschen abgefertigt
werden und sie dann dort empfang zu
nehmen sie zu verteilen irgendwo
hinzubringen das muss jetzt sofort
geschehen paul vielleicht kannst du uns
noch mal erklären die bilder die wir
jetzt gesehen haben sind von menschen
die flüchten wirklich nur das nötigste
mitnehmen können andererseits haben wir
ja immer wieder auch betont die ukraine
das ist europa das ist eine moderne
junge stadt das ist das berlin des
ostens wie ich vorhin schon einmal
gesagt habe wir haben keine bilder von
not und armut gesehen aber trotzdem ist
die situation
inwiefern ist die situation trotzdem
jetzt dramatisch auch was das
finanzielle angeht brauchen wir wie
sollen wir spenden sammeln sollen wir
geld schicken was sollen wir tun
also wenn wir über das generelle
sprechen dann geht es darum druck zu
machen dass dieser krieg erst mal
aufhört das ist ein waffenstillstand
gibt und dann tatsächlich humanitäre
güter geschickt werden können ich habe
jetzt keinen überblick über die
spenden möglichkeiten aber die gibt es
sicherlich und hier gibt es sehr gute
organisationen die klassischen auch ein
herz für kinder wird helfen von bild
aber es gibt natürlich auch unicef und
weitere die glaube ich hier gute arbeit
leisten und von denen ich weiß dass sie
noch einzelne lokale leute hier haben es
ist richtig als ich nach ihr kommen aus
der ost ukraine bin ich auf einer auto
streckte eine art autobahn gefahren und
wir waren das einzige auto erfasst das
sind die eine richtung gefahren ist und
uns sind wirklich hunderttausende
tausende zehntausende hunderttausende
entgegengekommen auf dieser strecke das
war wirklich etwas was ich noch nie
erlebt habe in einem krisengebiet in
dieser intensität die frage ist die sich
viele menschen stellen die jetzt schnell
geflüchtet den thomas binn geht es ja
darum dass sie wieder kommen könnte
hoffen dass dieser krieg nicht allzu
lange dauert die hoffen dass die
russische armee eben nicht komplett
besetzt ich merke bei meinen
ukrainischen freundin eine große
nervosität die noch hier sind sie auch
mit arbeiten was die zukunft angeht wenn
russland ihr die stadt besetzen sollte
also die berichte über mögliche listen
wir haben über vitali klitschko selenz
die auch lade ich schon gesprochen dass
die dann tage ziel seien würden aber das
betrifft ja sehr viele weitere menschen
es geht um aktivisten um
politiker insgesamt es geht um menschen
die vielleicht einen
homosexuellen hintergrund haben all dies
was für russland ja für das feindbild
russland steht diese menschen sind in
gefahr und sicherlich auch diejenigen
die mit dem militär gearbeitet habe mit
dem ukrainischen militär man muss sich
nichts vormachen es gibt wahrscheinlich
keine stadt ein land dass russland so
infiltriert hat wie die ukraine das ist
in den vergangenen jahrzehnten natürlich
gewachsen aber insbesondere seit dem
majdan seit 2000 wird denn ich glaube es
gibt keinen ministerium es gibt dann
keine
behörde wo russland keine spione hat das
heißt die wissen ganz genau wer hier was
gemacht hat auch auf den unteren ebenen
und das macht viele menschen nervös paul
bleibt bitte mal in der leitung wir
haben eine breaking news über die ich
gerne mit dir und mit herrn thome gleich
sprechen möchte
[Musik]
und zwar hat der russische
delegationsleiter bei der
un-klimakonferenz in paris sich gerade
für den ukrainer krieg entschuldigt der
russische delegationsleiter bei der
un-klimakonferenz in paris also in der
westlichen welt entschuldigt sich für
den krieg putin
kann man wirklich sagen paul wie ist
deine einschätzung auch von kiefer aus
du kennst russland auch sehr genau kann
man sagen dass putin zunehmend isoliert
werden könnte
das hoffe ich thomas allerdings glaube
ich dass der delegationsleiter der dort
gerade weil es ist wahrscheinlich nicht
so schnell zurück wie wird nach moskau
sondern eher in paris bleiben wird weil
nämlich wenn er zu fliegen würde er
wahrscheinlich sofort in den knast kommt
das problem oder die große sorge ist
einfach dass der militärapparat der
geheimdienst unklar die mir putin
diejenigen die ihn beschützen auch die
oligarchen dass die stehen und solange
der sicherheitsbereich und die armee
hinter dem präsidenten stehen bzw
so viel druck verspürt dass sie hinter
dem präsidenten stehen müssen werden sie
weiterhin alles tun um diesen zu
beschützen wir haben das bei den
demonstrationen gesehen wie polizisten
auf die menschen los knüppeln wie
hunderte festgenommen wurde wir erleben
wie es insgesamt natürlich eine kampagne
gibt gegen all diejenigen die versuchen
das unterschiedlich zu sehen nur muss
ich sagen selbst leute die routine
freunde vielleicht waren oder auf seiner
seite standen politisch auch aus dieser
richtung höre ich mittlerweile
das ist alles nur wahnsinn was hier
passiert wir hätten damit nicht
gerechnet wir stehen auch nicht hinter
diesem krieg das ist unser bruder volk
was passiert dort warum macht er das das
macht alles keinen sinn und das ist der
große unterschied thomas zu dem was 2014
passiert ist und da war es so dass eine
propaganda daran dass die nato ist das
sind die bösen und jetzt holen wir uns
erst die halbinsel krim zurück das
sogenannte geschenk 1 an die ukraine und
dass es wieder russisch da gab es diesen
begeisterung und da hat das gut
geschafft seine innenpolitische schwäche
überdecken mit der außenpolitischen und
ist in den werten in den ratings
wahnsinnig nach oben geschnellt
möglicherweise weil also ja von der
außenwelt abgeschnitten ist hatte er
gedacht dass das auch jetzt wieder
passiert also dass wir hören jetzt in
diesem moment wieder
raketen
alarmsirenen wir wollen einmal reinhören
wenn es vielleicht wieder losgeht dass
ihr das noch einmal mitbekommen könnt
wie das hier sozusagen in der stadt
abläuft solange erzähle ich noch einmal
weiter wie das ganze zu bewerten ist was
jetzt
das sind die geräusche
die davor warnen dass möglicherweise ein
luftangriff bevorstehen könnte es
vielleicht please film erzählt von sagen
wir zeigen und ich das jetzt einmal
vielleicht auch durch die scheibe ganz
kurz
sind einmal ganz still und lauschen der
nacht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also die sirenen heulen einmal kurz dann
verstummt es in dieser wahnsinnigen
stille ihr von hier wo man wirklich
nichts hört und
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so
also thomas das sind die das sind die
wir machen mal wieder das fenster zu
sozusagen das sind die sirenen die
losgehen so lange bei uns keine zweite
sirene los geht bleiben wir im zimmer
wenn eine zweite sirene hören sie im
hintergrund eine zweite sirene los geht
begeben wir uns dann ihnen den bunker du
siehst man gewöhnt sich schon etwas
daran das wollte ich dich gerade fragen
so geht es ja den bewohnern von kiew und
auch die rund auch peter hell und dem
ganzen team das für uns berichtet
gewöhnt man sich daran oder habt ihr
angst
nein angst muss ich sagen habe ich nicht
sondern respekt davor
und hier noch eine sirene im hintergrund
respekt davor
vorsichtig zu sein in so einer situation
und keine risiken einzugehen die nicht
notwendig sind aber wie als reporter
müssen eben unseren job machen und das
müssen wir oder sollten wir aus meiner
sicht eben aus gier tun wo etwas
passiert wo etwas historisches passiert
wo etwas passiert thomas was sich viele
menschen auch viele jungen menschen nie
hätten vorstellen können dass das noch
einmal möglich ist in europa und ich als
jemand der so viele jahre über die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer über den
ukrainer berichtet hat kühle auch eine
verpflichtung die nicht alleine zu
lassen
pauli bleibt so lange bei uns wie du
kannst und dann runter musste dann
verschwindest du einfach so lange halte
will ich hier bei uns im gespräch hätten
sie sich das jemals träumen lassen alb
träumen lassen muss man sagen dass es zu
einem solchen eroberungskrieg in europa
noch einmal kommen könnte also solche
geschichten solche dinge solche bilder
kenne ich aus geschichtsbüchern aus
historienfilme wir hatten gehofft dass
so dass ein für alle mal vorbei sein
würde wenn sich länder staaten noch
einmal bekriegen dann vielleicht auf
technischem wege durch durch cyber wo
oder finanz oder handelskriege aber noch
noch einmal panzer auffahren würden das
habe ich persönlich für eine höchst
unwahrscheinliche eigentlich obsolete
der vergangenheit angehören de form der
auseinandersetzung zwischen völkern
gehalten und deswegen habe ich übrigens
bis zum letzten tag bis mittwoch nicht
geglaubt dass putin aus diesem szenario
wahrheit machen würde das hat auch mich
persönlich
vollkommen buchstäblich im schlaf
überrascht paul eine andere nachricht
die heute ja sehr bedrohlich klang war
dass belarus ebenfalls also weißrussland
lukaschenko der diktator dort ebenfalls
truppen richtung ukraine schicken wollte
dass also die ukraine dann sozusagen von
zwei ländern angegriffen werden russland
und
weißrussland da hat der ukrainische
präsident seelands gehen zwischen einem
telefonat mit dem weißrussischen
diktator lukaschenko
geführt und wie gesagt geh bitte einfach
runter wenn du runter muster war
ansonsten höre einfach mit zu was
zielinski danach gesagt nein ich
das gespräch mit alexander lukaschenko
war sehr sachlich ich möchte nicht dass
raketen flugzeuge und hubschrauber von
weißrussland in die ukraine fliegen
programm
wenn es ab
na ja sagt dann ich möchte nicht dass
truppen aus weißrussland in die ukraine
gehen das hat er mir versichert
also lukaschenko einer der schlimmsten
und wie wir lange gesagt haben letzten
diktatoren in europa mittlerweile müssen
wir sagen putin ist ein weiterer
versichert selensky dass keine truppen
geschickt werden würden wie glaubhaft
ist dass
das halte ich für eine völlig
unglaubwürdige aussage von lukas schinko
ist genauso ein lügner genauso ein
verbrecher wie bloody mir putin und was
er am telefon sagt hat keinen wert an
sich
lukaschenko das sieht man in satelliten
aufnahmen das sieht man auch jetzt an
erkenntnissen die verschiedenen dienste
haben die aber auch im social media
bereich
geteilt werden dort ist zu erkennen dass
es diese truppen bewegung gab und das
ist sie auch immer noch gibt die frage
ist vor allem was mit der belarussischen
luftwaffe passiert da gab es nämlich die
spekulation dass diese jetzt auch
eingesetzt werden würde sagen wieso wenn
sich das verstärken sollte dann wird das
rauskommt und herr lukaschenko erneut
als das ja als das dastehen der ist im
er ist einfach jemand der sich putin
verschrieben hat dadurch dass seine
revolution die revolution der opposition
protection of ska ja die dann das land
aus dem land flüchten musste die
gewählte präsidentin und wo er das
ergebnis nicht anerkannt hatte ich war
selbst dabei den demonstrationen damals
hunderttausende millionen auf den
straßen und lukas schenkel konnte diese
protest ja nur niederschlagen weil die
mir putin geheimdienstler geschickt hat
wladimir putin sicherheitskräfte
geschickt hat und weil wladimir putin zu
ihm stand und klar war dass jeglicher
aufstand der bevölkerung
niedergeschlagen würde in dramatischer
weise und dann hat er das ganz
klassische russische system verfolgt er
hat tausende einsperren lassen unter das
gemacht was putin gesagt hat und jetzt
muss er zurückzahlen und das bedeutet
einen wahnsinnigen krieg führen zusammen
mit wladimir putin der auch bedeutet
dass viele menschen viele soldaten
zumindest ausbilder russ sterben
paul platzmitte weiter bei uns frage
einen thome paul hat gerade die
demonstration von damals in kiew
angesprochen heute gab es große dem eine
riesige demonstration muss man sagen in
berlin möglicherweise bis zu 500.000
menschen waren dort auf den beinen wie
sehr hat sie das beeindruckt wir hatten
ja zur gleichen zeit der sondersitzung
im bundestag nur wenige meter von der
demonstration
entfernt vor dem brandenburger tor es
war mit 20.000 bestenfalls erhöht worden
es war mindestens das zehnfache ein
vielfaches davon auf der straße und es
ist schon sehr sehr beeindruckend zeigt
auch dass das allgemein dieses vorgehen
putins dass dieser krieg als als etwas
völlig illegitimes gegen jede moral
gegen das völkerrecht angesehen während
übrigens interessanterweise ich stimme
dem ganz und gar zu was passiert sei mal
so eben sagte dass das sowohl für putin
also für lukaschenko lüge ein instrument
der politik ist aber eines zeigt es dann
doch dass sie zu diesem mittel der lüge
greifen sie müssen ihrem tun ein
anstrich verleihen sie können nicht
einfach so sagen was wir tun ist völlig
legal völlig legitime wehren uns gegen
einen angriff der ukraine gegen den bau
einer nuklearwaffe der ukraine nein sie
müssen dem ganzen durch das mittel der
lüge ein anstrich verleihen und das
zeigt ein anderes was sie vorher schon
ebenfalls angesprochen hatten putin ist
noch umgeben von den silowiki den
schafen den falken aber dass auf der
straße vor sich gehe das seine eigenen
leute ein vertreter in paris dass die
menschen in russland auch nicht mehr
voll und ganz hinter ihm stehen das
entgeht ihm das auch ein wichtiges
zeichen
und von daher kann man insgesamt sagen
booten ist da wohl sehr lukaschenko ist
es ebenfalls nur durch dieses mittel der
lüge und die menschen zu hintergehen nur
so gelingt es ihnen ihrem tun den
anstrich des legalen zu verleihen der
unterschied jetzt hier sind die menschen
nach der demonstration nach hause
gegangen in russland werden sie
verhaftet netto mehr ganz herzlichen
dank für ihren besuch im studio power
bleibt weiter uns bei uns schön in der
mitte wir tauschen einfach mal die gäste
aus hätte mir ganz herzlichen dank und
wenn sie einfach nicht schiebt sie jetzt
sozusagen aus dem bild heraus und dafür
konnten svenja bartels der eine ist der
ehemalige wehrbeauftragte des
bundestages hallo herr babbel setzte
sich in position erstellen sie sich
einfach hier uns dazu wir haben paul
ronzheimer mit in der leitung der in
kiel ist sie haben nebenan in unserem
besucherraum hier direkt neben dem
studio gesessen und konnten das programm
vielleicht mit verfolgen ist das richtig
ich habe ein bisschen gesehen war das
heißt wir haben wir gesehen wie also
dunkel liegt die stadt gespenstisch
schwarz und die sirenen heulen welche
bilder gehen dabei ihnen durch den kopf
naja das ist nicht eigenes erleben aber
was man aus der deutschen geschichte
weiß ist dass krieg so aussieht werner
in die städte kommt wenn er die
zivilbevölkerung erreicht und das ist
etwas was wir uns wirklich in europa
nicht hätten träumen lassen und auch
nicht dulden wollen wir wollen paul
wieder mit ins gespräch weil wir
sprechen wollen darüber dass deutschland
auf rüstet man kann es so deutlich sagen
pauli diese nachrichten zum einen
gestern ja dass waffen geliefert werden
sollen jetzt also doch jetzt also
endlich zur unterstützung in die ukraine
und dann heute die rede von olaf scholz
also ein sondervermögen bundeswehr mit
100 milliarden euro und deutschland will
die nato verpflichtung nun auch erfüllen
und sogar mehr als zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsproduktes für
militärausgaben bereitstellt kommt es so
was in diesen zeiten in diesen tagen in
der ukraine an außer bei der politischen
führung merken die menschen das auch als
ein zeichen der solidarität
die menschen die haben sicherlich andere
sorgen ob jetzt deutschland 100
milliarden mehr ausgibt oder nicht für
das militär ich finde das richtig
absolut richtige fand auch die rede von
olaf scholz stark in kiew erste er das
gefühl auch bei der bevölkerung dass sie
sich von deutschland im stich gelassen
gefühlt haben das bedeutet nicht dass
man das jetzt schlecht findet ganz im
gegenteil viele sagen endlich
warum brauchte es erst diesen krieg um
das zu verstehen warum brauchte er ist
erst tote in der ukraine um das zu
verstehen denn man muss ja eins sagen
dass es sozusagen hier diese
aufforderung aus der ukraine gab dass
waffen geliefert werden sollten das galt
der abschreckung also man hatte gehofft
die ukrainische führung das wenn es
besonders viele westliche waffen gebe
dass wladimir putin sich das überlegen
würde ob er wirklich angreift aus meiner
sicht sicherlich auch eher illusorisch
denn man sieht ja das war die mutigen
der kriegsvorbereitung auf falsche leute
bislang zumindest gehört hat und seine
strategie nicht aufgeht also
wahrscheinlich hätte er sich da von
westlichen waffen nicht abschrecken
lassen unabhängig davon wenn wir auch
das militärische schauen oder was da
passiert ist was mir aufgefallen dass in
dieser bundestag sitzung und herr
bartels hat er sicherlich auch seine
erfahrung war das bild des botschafters
des ukrainischen botschaft dass andere
wenig ich kann ihn sehr lange hast schon
seit vier oder fünf jahren glaube ich
botschafter in deutschland und ich habe
aus der politik von minister von
bundestagsabgeordneten in den
vergangenen monaten muss ich sagen also
als ich noch in berlin war immer wieder
gehört das ist ja unmöglich was der
ukrainische botschafter der macht der
beleidigt und der sagt dass wir warten
die von sollen das ist doch nicht gut
das ist ein kriegstreiber das haben sie
nicht angesagt wie man die journalisten
sprache sagt aber im hintergrund und
dann dieses bild plötzlich 600 oder wie
viel da wir mittlerweile haben an
bundestagsabgeordnete über 700 über 700
das erste mal bundestag genau über 700
bundestagsabgeordnete standing ovations
gegeben haben dem ukrainischen botschaft
da und da ich schon doch wie verlogen
politik sein kann und jetzt plötzlich so
alle so tun als hätten sie schon bewusst
dass die ukraine unterstützt werden
müssten eine interessante begebenheit in
diesem zusammenhang paul wir hatten an
rebellen gestern hier im studio
irgendwann ich weiß gar nicht mehr wir
haben wir zehn stunden durch gesendet
ich glaube es war im laufe des
vormittags war er hier und dann sprach
er darüber dass er gleich einen termin
mit christine lambrecht der
verteidigungsminister seinen hätte und
er wüsste nicht was da auf ihn zukommen
würde aber er habe ein zeichen bekommen
dass sich etwas bewegen soll und dann
habe ich ihn vor hin wieder hier im
studio getroffen und er konnte sein
glück gar nicht fassen dass tatsächlich
etwas in bewegung geraten ist aber wohl
wer herrn bartels mit herein er war es
an der zeit deutschland aufzurüsten um
es auch so drastisch zu sagen denn
deutschland ist ein herr friedens als
ein kriegs bewegt das land und das ja
auch aus gutem grund das heißt man alles
das was wir heute von olaf scholz gehört
haben mag spät sein aber besser spät als
nicht oder nie und was ein wenig an
druck gemacht hat in der tat das ist zum
teil
beschimpft worden oder belächelt je
nachdem ich habe das als verzweiflung
wahrgenommen also das ist ein land die
ukraine ja nicht mitgeben bündnissystem
ist und insofern sich nur auf sich
selbst verlassen kann ihr dabei zu
helfen sich selbst zu verteidigen das
kann nicht falsch sein da gibt's keine
moralische rechtfertigung zu sagen uns
wegen unserer geschichte können wir die
um keine nicht helfen also genau wegen
unserer geschichte müssen wir einen
bedrohten angegriffenen land in dem
deutsche truppen schon schlimmstes
angerichtet haben heute helfen aber was
die bundeswehr angeht ist das natürlich
ein sehr gutes zeichen dass olaf scholz
heute
also eine ganze
neue epoche angekündigt hat also er
selbst sprach von einem zeitenwandel den
deutschland in die welt erlebt und in
diesem zeitenwandel soll ist auch für
die bundeswehr einen aufbruch geben
nämlich hin zu einer voll ausgestatteten
armee sie haben ist das wort aufrüstung
gebraucht ich weiß gar nicht ob da was
aufzurüsten ist zunächst mal geht es um
die volle ausstattung einer armee von
185.000 soldaten die heute nicht voll
einsatzfähig sind erwartet wenn ich bin
ich eine frage stellen dafür was ich
mich gefragt habe als ich die nachricht
gehört habe dass hunderten milliarden
euro jetzt in die bundeswehr investiert
werden habe ich mir die frage gestellt
wer es dann auch vielleicht besser wenn
wir eine ministerin hätten die sich
auskennt mit dem was sie tut als frau
lambrecht wir nun wirklich jetzt am
gestolpert ist dann sich wahnsinnig
solidarisch gezeigt hat die ukraine eine
große pressekonferenz gemacht hat und
stolz verkündet hat dass die 5000 helmes
schickt was hier in der ganzen welt
deutschland blamiert hat bis hin in die
usa und vor allem rechte auch nicht
aufgefallen ist als die man als die sich
überhaupt mit militär mit verteidigung
auskennt wie vorher justizministerin sie
hat auch in dem ganzen außenpolitischen
verteidigungspolitischen war ich
überhaupt keine rolle gespielt ich finde
wir sollten die ministerin auswechseln
wenn wir dieses amt zu wichtig machen er
war leider haben wir noch 20 sekunden es
ist ein ja oder nein das sagen können
ist dass die richtige ministerin die
übrigens auch noch zwischendurch mal
ganz schnell familienministerin war man
kann ja alles oder vielleicht demnächst
innenministerin wird ich weiß es nicht
da bin ich auch die falsche adresse für
die bundeswehr ist nicht ganz glücklich
damit dass immer wieder neue ministerin
sich einarbeiten mussten wenn ein ja
durchaus komplexes thema aber
sozusagen jetzt hat sie eine große
aufgabe
ganz herzlichen dank herr bartels ganz
herzlichen danke paul der eine weitere
gespenstischen nacht vor sich hat passt
gut auf dort paule und zwar alle ihr das
ganze team dort die ihr für uns
berichtet